in a town like Las Vegas you don't
always have to play the hand you were
dealt PCI dealer School the sponsors of
this segment offers an exciting and
lucrative career path
[Music]
hi I'm Jesse Lauer I'm the owner of PCI
dealer School
Jesse you guys have been part of the
fabric of The Gaming Community for over
30 years how did it all begin oh it
started in 1985 with my father and his
best friend Bill Zender they started the
school when Vegas was booming and it's
continued on ever since then and you
took over in 2014. i i after I was a
dealer from 1997 to 2014 and then my
father decided to retire and I
transitioned into taking over the school
what I like about YouTube you're still
out there dealing right yes yeah I'm
back I recently went back to dealing at
one of your major strip properties I
absolutely love dealing and I love being
a part of it and then teaching people
and helping them get a career out of it
your graduates what properties have they
gone on to work with we help people get
in all your local casinos a handful of
your downtown casinos and your ample
your strip casinos so outside of
blackjack what games do you guys teach
well we currently have our most popular
program which is three games of your
choice for 499 dollars obviously
Blackjack roulette baccarat craps pie
out poker and then we also have your
novelty games such as ultimate Texas
Hold'em three card poker and high card
plush that's awesome you guys cover so
many games so many people in your school
right now how does it work as far as
scheduling the schedule is up to the
individual so every student can enroll
any day Monday through Friday once
they're enrolled they can come as much
as they want from open to close no
appointment needed you just come and go
as you please and learn at your own pace
we encourage the students to come as
much as possible because the more you're
here the more time you have studying and
practicing and learning the quicker
you'll learn and get the job that we
will help you as with assistance with so
you help with job placement but you've
told me before that sometimes Casino
Executives come in here looking for
importance right A lot of times ever
since covid went away and Vegas got
busier the casinos have actually started
coming right to the school and
auditioning and hiring right on site
which is amazing it's great for the
students it makes them more relaxed they
have fun and they get jobs all right
Jesse day one I'm ready to learn
Blackjack what do you got first thing we
do is we learn how to cut chips properly
25 50 75 100. pretty fast all right
after we do that we learn how to shuffle
the cards you're going to work your way
from one deck up to two decks this is
two decks
after you learn how to shuffle the cards
properly then we'll start teaching you
that how to deal Blackjack there's three
versions of blackjack
shoe double deck face up and double deck
pitch all right Jesse step one cutting
improving the checks yes we grab a
hundred dollars and we do 25 50 75 100
splash
that was okay
and here I am over here I need some I
need some training we will be happy to
properly train you and help you with job
placement assistance where do I sign up
right over here at the front desk all
right I'll see you in a bit
now we have an in yeah no kidding yeah
thanks to PCI dealer school for
sponsoring this segment you can give
them a call at that phone number on the
screen in little print
702-877-4724 or visit their website
PCI dealerschool.com there's a limited
time offer right now you can call to
enroll in their three-game package for
499 dollars which offers training
certificate and job placement assistance